clasifica el cuadrilátero abc de elige
la opción que se ajuste mejor al
cuadrilátero y aquí nos dan los cuatro
puntos que conforman este cuadrilátero y
nos dan sus coordenadas y nos dicen
bueno elige si es un cuadrado rombo
rectángulo paralelogramo trapecio o
ninguno de los anteriores anteriores
perdón y nos dice elige la opción que se
ajuste mejor porque definitivamente todo
cuadrado es un rombo también todo
cuadrado es un rectángulo y todos los
cuadrados rombos y rectángulos son
paralelo gramos pero no pasa al revés
verdad no todo paralelogramo es un rombo
ni todo el rectángulo es un cuadrado ok
también nos ponen la opción de que puede
ser un trapecio o ninguno de los
anteriores entonces para resolver este
problema vamos a ir viendo gráficamente
en este en este plano coordinado muy
bien entonces vamos a poner el punto y
el punto a es el punto 16 así que vamos
a poner el 1
veis que anda por aquí aquí estará el
punto
este es el a muy bien entonces después
del punto b nos dice que es el menos 52
vamos a poner el menos 5,2 aquí está el
punto b y una vez le voy a poner menos
5,2 y en la era el 16 muy bien ahora
vámonos con el punto ce el punto se es
menos 7,8 éste está muy arriba aquí está
el punto ce muy bien es menos 7,8 muy
bien y finalmente vamos a poner el punto
d el punto d se encuentra en 2,11 y éste
se va a salir de la pantalla aquí está
el 28 9 10 11 vamos a ponerlo aquí el
punto de igual al 2,11 muy bien no no se
sale de la pantalla sino sólo se sale de
nuestro cuadro muy bien entonces el
cuadrilátero sólo resulta de unir estos
puntos
voy a tratar de hacerlo lo mejor que
pueda ahí está
ok luego conectamos beck 11
ahí está luego se con de ok vamos a
intentarlo
ahí está se conde y finalmente de con
ok ok oops más o menos más o menos
entonces a primera vista se ve que ave
podría bueno quizás lo pinte mal verdad
puede ser que a ver si sea paralelo a cd
pero quién definitivamente no es para
quienes no son paralelos son el lado b c
y el lado de a entonces ni puede ser
cuadrado ni rumbo ni rectángulo tampoco
paralelogramo entonces la opción que
podríamos tener es que el lado c d sea
paralelo al lado ave y entonces fuera un
trapecio muy bien entonces como
podríamos determinar si estos dos lados
son paralelos y eso lo podemos hacer
simplemente analizando la pendiente
verdad la pendiente de este segmento lo
podríamos calcular y ver si es igual a
la pendiente de este otro segmento
entonces recordemos que la pendiente es
nuestro cambio en y dividido entre
nuestro cambio en x muy bien y de hecho
quizás debería ponerlo más allá
un poco más retirado para que pueda yo
dibujar muy bien entonces la pendiente
la pendiente es el cambio y dividido
entre el cambio en x muy bien entonces
como calculamos nuestro cambio en y
esencialmente tendremos que pintar un
triángulo rectángulo
vamos a pintarle un poquito mejor ahí lo
tienen entonces este cambio es
esencialmente lo que nos movimos desde b
hasta y nuestro cambio y fue ir desde 2
hasta 6 que esencialmente es 6 -2 muy
bien entonces 6 menos 2 es simplemente 4
muy bien aumentamos 4 ahora cuanto nos
movimos en la dirección horizontal
fíjense muy bien que es lo mismo que
poner 1 - menos 51 menos menos cinco que
esto es 6 muy bien esencialmente es ver
cuánto mide esta distancia ok y entonces
la respuesta final es dos tercios ahora
vamos a ver si está pendiente coincide
con la pendiente de aquí cuál es nuestro
cambio oops nuestro cambio y vamos de
hecho voy a ponerle un poquito más allá
porque este triángulo viene
de esta forma muy bien entonces quién es
nuestro cambio en ya dividido entre
nuestro cambio en x bueno quizás sea más
fácil primero ver el cambio en x estamos
en menos 7 y terminamos en 2 así que
tendríamos dos menos menos 7 que esto es
2 más 7 que son 9 ahora cuál es nuestro
cambio en que tenemos que empezamos en 8
y terminamos en 11 es decir tenemos 11
menos 8 y esto es 3 y esto es igual a un
tercio muy bien entonces definitivamente
las pendientes no fueron iguales así que
si no son iguales las pendientes las dos
rectas no son paralelas así que
concluimos que ninguno de los lados es
paralelo con ninguno de los otros por lo
que no es un paralelogramo tampoco puede
ser un rombo ni bueno más bien no es ni
un rombo ni cuadrado ni rectángulo ni
paralelogramo entonces tampoco puede ser
un trapecio porque los trapecios tienen
un par de la del b lados paralelos así
que nos vamos por elegir la opción d
de los anteriores